afin de l'entretien entre vladimir
poutine emmanuel macron il s'agit là de
la suite des diverses réunions entre
veux qu'ils ont eu lieu ces dernières
semaines au sujet de la crise
ukrainienne un entretien bon les
conclusions n'ont pas encore été
communiqués l'elysée confirme seulement
l'appel téléphonique entre le président
français et celui de l'ukraine volodymyr
zelensky ce sera à 19 heures heure de
paris la france qui affirme vouloir
dialoguer mais s'aligne sur les
positions américaines et promis de
riposter en cas d'invasion de l'ukraine
par la russie ce que moscou a toujours
démenti ce matin dans une interview
sergueï lavrov a été clair le ministre a
réaffirmé l'intention de son pays la
russie ne veut pas la guerre et a choisi
depuis longtemps la voie de la
diplomatie
moscou qui se sont par ailleurs menacé
par l'extension de l'otan et par le
soutien occidental à kiev le point avec
avait à gauche même
si cela dépend uniquement de la russie
il n'y aura pas de guerre en ukraine a
déclaré le chef de la diplomatie russe
sergueï lavrov lors de l'interview par
quatre stations de radio aux russes
l'interview a duré une heure et demie
est touché tout un éventail de sujets
concernant la politique internationale
russe sergueï lavrov assuré que la
russie n'avait pas l'intention
d'attaquer qui que ce soit mais n'a pas
exclu qu'il y avait des forces
extérieures qui souhaiteraient une
escalade dans la région je vous propose
d'écouter on sous-entend que tout dépend
de nous et nous n'avons qu'à claquer des
doigts et poussera vion mais le kiev il
a compris que berlin et paris ne vont
pas le forcer à respecter les accords de
minsk et comme aux jeunes ce qui a agi
nous n'aimons pas les accords de minsk
mais elles sont importantes parce que
cela nous permet de garder les sanctions
occidentales contre la russie se dit
cynisme pur et rien d'autre ils
comprennent que là ils peuvent faire
tout ce qu'ils veulent et
on l'utilisé on l'utilisé l'aise qui est
son régime avant tout ce sont des
américains qu'ils utilisent pour attiser
les tensions
ah
et avec sérieux les rosalies en europe
qui
font de même et la glu gage c'est pas le
sort de la crème l'important c'est de à
attiser la tension autour de la
fédération de russie pour en venir au
bout de ce sujet et s'en prendre à la
chine le ministre a également évoqué les
sanctions qui seraient en préparation
aux états unis et qui toucheraient des
hauts responsables russes y compris
vladimir poutine et sergueï lavrov en
personne écoutez en ce qui concerne les
menaces des sanctions on a dit aux
américains y compris pendant les
contacts entre les présidents que ce
temps semble des sanctions donc romain
de vous venez de mentionner ou ont pris
fois le blocage du système financier
économique et contrôlée par l'occident
ce serait équivalent à la rupture des
relations s'étaient dit directement
juste je pense qu'il le comprenne et je
pense pas que ce soit aux intérêts de
quelques ans lors de l'interview il a
été également question des propositions
russes en matière de sécurité mutuelle
que la russie avait promis aux états
unis et a le temps en décembre 2021
sergueï lavrov a encore une fois
souligné que pour la russie la question
de l' architecture de sécurité
européenne était un sujet essentiel et
que les autorités russes allaient
continuer le dialogue dans ce domaine